Conditional PDFs share most
of the properties
of conditional PMFs.
All facts for the discrete case
have continuous analogs.
The intuition is more or less
the same, although it is much
easier to grasp in the
discrete case.
For example, we have seen this
version of the total
probability theorem.
There is a continuous
analog in which we
replace sums by integrals.
And we replace PMFs by PDFs.
The proof of this fact is
actually pretty simple.
By the multiplication rule, the
integrand, here, is just
the joint PDF of X and Y.
And we know that if we take the
joint PDF and integrate
with respect to one variable
then we recover the marginal
PDF of the other random
variable.
So this is one theorem
that extends to
the continuous case.
Moving along, we have defined
the conditional expectation in
this manner in the
discrete case.
And we define it similarly
for the continuous case.
So actually here we now
have a new definition.
This definition is also
consistent with the definition
of the expectation of a
continuous random variable.
The expected value for
continuous random variable is
the integral of X times [a]
density.
Except that here we live in a
conditional universe where
we're conditioning
on this event.
And therefore, we
need to use the
corresponding conditional PDF.
Finally, we have the total
expectation theorem in the
discrete case.
And there is the obvious analog
in the continuous case
where we are using an integral
and a density.
The interpretation is that we
consider all possibilities for
Y. Under each possibility of Y
we find the expected value of
X. And then we weigh those
different possibilities
according to the corresponding
values of the density.
So we're taking a weighted
average of these conditional
expectations to obtain the
overall expectation of the
random variable X.
The derivation of this fact is
maybe a little instructive
because it uses various facts
that we have in our hands.
So let's see how to derive it.
We start from this expression in
the right-hand side and we
will show that it is equal to
the expected value of X. The
expression on the right-hand
side is equal to the
following, it's the integral
of the density of Y.
And then, inside here, we have
the conditional expectation
which is defined this way.
So we just plug-in
the definition.
And then what we do, is we take
this term and move it
inside the integral.
Which we can do because this
integral is with respect to x.
And therefore, this is
like a constant.
And we also interchange the
order of integration.
Now, the inner integration
is with respect to y.
As far as Y is concerned, this
term, x, is a constant.
So we can take it and move it
outside this first integral
and place it out there.
So this term disappears
and goes out there.
What do we have here?
This part, by the previous fact,
the total probability
theorem, is just the density of
X. So we're left with the
integral of x times the
density of x dx.
And this is the expected
value of X.
Finally, we have various forms
of the expected value rule,
which barely deserve
writing down.
Because they're exactly
what you might expect.
Consider, for example, an
expression such as this one,
the expected value of a
function of the random
variable X but conditioned on
the value of the random
variable Y. How do we calculate
this quantity?
Well, the expected value rule
tells us that we should
integrate g of x times the
density of X. But because,
here we live in a conditional
universe, we should actually
use the corresponding
conditional PDF of X. And
there are many other versions
of the expected value rule.
Any version that we have seen
for the discrete case has,
also, a continuous analog which
looks about the same
except that we integrate and
that we use densities.